good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric Gershon today we talk
chemistry climate and science policy
with Paula nastas director of Yale
Center for green chemistry and green
engineering often called the father of
green chemistry he has served in a
series of high-level federal science
policy posts most recently as assistant
administrator of the US EPA where he led
research in the White House Office of
Science and Technology Policy he was
assistant director for the environment
as always we'll take some of your
questions tweet us at Yale or email us
at social media at yale.edu Paul Anastos
thanks for being with us it's my
pleasure thanks for having me my
pleasure
I'd like to ask you a question first
about an essay that you wrote as a
schoolboy I gather that somehow or other
was noticed by the administration of
Richard Nixon tell us tell us that story
about what was he essay about and you
have any idea how the Nixon
administration came to know about it
that is it that's a true story that's
funny because so I up in Quincy
Massachusetts oh it's a small town right
south of Boston and I was overlooking
this beautiful wetland teeming with
wildlife all kinds of birds and I think
until the bulldozers rolled in and the
bulldozers rolled in and now if you go
up to where I was born you'll see
nothing but glass buildings of banks and
insurance companies so I was furious and
I among other things I wrote this essay
because the EPA had just been founded
and they were trying to popularize it
and get attention and so I wrote that
essay as part of an essay contest never
thinking that I was going to be
receiving some kind of recognition from
Richard Nixon
that's who do you still have it oh it's
on my wall if you go to my office here
Yale you will see my plaque from Richard
Nixon when I was 8 years old
so you went on you became a scientist
you're often called the father of green
chemistry
how did the term come about and what is
green chemistry so I'm very proud to be
part of a worldwide community of folks
that are doing green chemistry the the
term people think I'm joking when they
say how did you come up with this term
green chemistry because back twenty
years ago not everything was green this
and green man but green conjures up
images of the environment in the natural
world but in the u.s. it's also the
color of our money and so really what
green chemistry is about is how do you
meet all of the goals of making things
healthier for people in the planet well
at the same time meeting your economic
goals and aligning those rather than
having them work at cross-purposes as
we've done for so long say more so Greve
chemistry looks at the world
recognizing that everything that we see
touch and feel is a chemical everything
that's the basis of our society and our
economy is made from a chemical and so
when we look at all of the positive that
chemistry has done revolutionized
medicine revolutionized agriculture
communications that cannot be dismissed
but it also has it has to be recognized
that we did it in a with a lot of
unintended consequences we we have to
recognize that there's been disasters
Love Canal what we're doing with with
climate changes we'll talk about today
what we're doing even far more recently
with the tragedy in West Virginia and
the contamination of water so green
chemistry is simply saying we can do
better at that and the same way that
we'd never accept a beautiful building
if it collapsed would never accept a
delicious meal if it was poisonous
there's there's no reason that we should
accept the kind of behavior of of
chemicals if they provide wonderful
function but they cause toxicity and
harm there's as I understand it sort of
twelve core principles of green
chemistry
is there a way to distill those twelve
to one fundamental principle yeah the
twelve principles go across the entire
lifecycle of a of a chemical from its
feedstocks to what it does during use
and end-of-life but really if you
distill it down to one statement its
design your products in your processes
so that they reduce or eliminate hazards
to human health in the environment
that's it looking at the intrinsic
hazard
how can green chemistry be used how is
it being used how might it be used to
help us address climate change is is
there is it mitigating climate change
and if not yet how could it yeah
absolutely
so across a wide spectrum green
chemistry is being applied to problems
that are directly relevant to climate
change so you obviously would start with
alternative energies alternative
energies that are non fossil based would
be the the key way the green chemistry
is addressing them I'd have to say right
here at Yale we have the Yale Energy
Institute and and some of the work there
and even in my own labs it's looking at
how you can split water to produce
hydrogen and as an energy source and and
in the process generate water back as a
by-product there's ways of looking at
renewables new generation biodiesel all
of these are directly related to to
green chemistry and and require
chemistry in order to to do this there's
also a key area that's always been part
of of chemistry that's now being looked
at and that is catalysis catalysis is
using a very small amount of a substance
to make things happen faster with less
waste and this has resulted in energy
efficiencies across every sector of our
economy
so yeah green chemistry and climate
change are I would say inextricably
linked science policy question you spent
a lot of time in Washington in various
capacity
and not so long ago do you think that
the science community could have done
better to convince policymakers and the
public of the significant threat climate
change poses to civilization
sooner and how might the science
community have done that yeah so
absolutely the I think that when we look
at any of the great grant challenges
that we're facing around sustainability
climate change being at the forefront
communication is a tremendous challenge
now the first chemists that I'm aware of
to raise a flag on climate change was
probably arena us back in 1896 and so
it's not that it hasn't been known that
increasing co2 levels are going to cause
these types of effects but the ability
to to communicate the ability to make
compelling cases and languages that
people can understand whether it's the
public whether it's policymakers I think
is a tremendous responsibility of the
scientific community and one that hasn't
been as embraced and engaged as it needs
to be you need to to speak the language
of the tribe you're talking to and if
you need to convince policymakers then
having a scientific definition of the
word uncertainty and a popular version
of the word uncertainty that can that
can and is causing so much difficulty in
the communication you you obviously get
that because you've just articulated it
nicely do you have the sense that the
other scientists working in science
policy positions in Washington are
really internalizing that and improving
at that well I'd suggest that maybe
there's been a bit of historical it's
not my job my job is to generate the the
data is to seek the truth and it's not
my job to to communicate or translate
I think that the that the scientific
community writ large is is is learning
the lessons and and in some cases
reaping the bit of fruit of of that lack
of emphasis on communication so there is
you know communicating factual
observations is not the same as becoming
a subjective advocate no scientist wants
to become a subjective advocate the
objectivity is absolutely essential but
being able to communicate that
objectivity it's my my perspective that
that's absolutely essential slightly
different take on a similar question
what is your view of the the
relationship between science and
government policy if it is they don't
always seem to be in sync right so when
you look at the at the fundamental
science that's generated the data that's
generated that is core foundational to
the to the scientific endeavor right but
then you start saying how do we put this
in the context of the role of government
and trying to help individuals help
Society and all of a sudden you have a
lot of of factors you want to make sure
that when that decision process is is
being made and of taking science and and
turning it into policy that it's not
that that it's being done with some
consistency and so you generate policies
protocols for how you use the science
getting those protocols for how you turn
science into policy takes time and
approval and go through many hurdles in
that time science is not standing still
so many of the protocols you're using to
form the policy are no longer using the
most up-to-date science this is
something that we need to address
recognize and resolve but it's a that
conflict between science and policy in
this area of science policy is a great
challenge I'm
take a question from a viewer this
question comes from Mark Johnson who
tweeted it at us
he asks should we change policy to
disaster mediation from fossil fuel
substitutes so when you look at the
current state of affairs with regard to
climate change I'm thinking that most
folks will realize that we are no longer
talking about avoiding the effects of
climate change climate changes here we
are going to have effects and I can
understand why the question is phrased
and do we simply engage in disaster
mitigation but I think actually John
Holdren who is the president's science
advisor said it best we have to manage
the unavoidable and avoid the
unmanageable so it's absolutely true
that we need to be thinking about
adaptation and President Obama
two or three days ago just announced a a
fund proposed a fund for climate
adaptation but I think it's equally
important that if we're going to avoid
the worst types of consequences of
climate change then we absolutely still
need to take every action available to
us Charlie another question this one by
Facebook from David Kim who asks will
energy consumption impact America as a
viable threat in the next 10 years well
our energy consumption well will energy
consumption impact America as a viable
threat in the next ten years which I it
sounds to me like is a question about
the way we're consuming energy now and
whether we need to change it ASAP yeah I
have to say that I'm I'm probably a
little bit of a heretic in these
discussions because we are really not
discussing whether we know we want to
minimize energy use we surrounded by
energy we're swimming and energy all
that we have in this world in this
universe is energy and Maddock what
we're talking about is is not minimizing
all energy that's that's really an a
possibility we're talking about the
nature of the energy so
when we start selecting the inherent
nature is it going to be renewable or is
it going to be depleting is it going to
be be minders are going to be harvested
whether it's harvested from from the Sun
or from from the ground so I'd say that
I'm all for using potentially even more
energy as long as the nature of that
energy is inherently more sustainable so
to follow up on that question I think it
was just yesterday that President Obama
announced that he's asked the EPA to
draw new tighter standards for fuel
efficiency for really big trucks right
so what would your take on that be oh
it's a it's a very important step it's
part of the the progression where
there's been addressing off-road
vehicles then there's the current
process of addressing there is power
plants that's ongoing even though these
large vehicles make up a relatively
small percentage of the of the vehicles
on the road I think it's four or five
percent of the vehicles on the road they
have the the energy demand in the in the
the impacts of about 50 percent of all
vehicle traffic so taking on that very
large issue I think is absolutely
essential and part of a strategy that I
think is being rolled out a lot of the
conversation about climate change and a
lot of the research seems to focus on
carbon dioxide and there are good
reasons and obvious reasons for that but
it's not the only greenhouse gas can you
talk a little bit about some of the
other greenhouse gases
perhaps methane that are also a serious
threat and how we can address some of
those certainly so when you look at some
of the the greenhouse gases co2 is
obviously first and foremost simply
because of volume the the volume that's
being pumped into the atmosphere is you
know when you have a Gigaton type of
issue that that tends to be the headline
but you're absolutely right
so when you look at our history of CFCs
see if the CFCs and we define that just
Oh certainly of chlorofluorocarbons
which we used as propellants they they
could be used as fire extinguishing
agents which were being phased out a
number of years ago under the Montreal
Protocol they could have a potency as a
greenhouse gas 10,000 times or more that
of co2
you mentioned methane that that is a
much more potent greenhouse gas but you
also have to weigh how long is it going
to stay in the atmosphere co2 might
build up for a century or more well a
lifetime of of methane is more potent
but a shorter life time so when we start
talking about energy shifts to methane
due to fracking and things like that I
need to know is that going to cause a
short term a short term spike in our
global climate change concerns besides
methane others yeah so the the Halen's
some of the people might remember the
old Nike sneakers called Nike Ayers well
the little bubble in Nike air that
wasn't filled with air so so that that
Halon was actually one that had a
greenhouse gas 26,000 times more potent
than yeah in co2 were then CEO Jim than
co2 so and of course that was phased out
by a wonderful green chemist and
invention by a person named Richard well
at the University of Delaware and now it
actually is air and the Nike airs but
even such things as water vapor the
reason why so many of the concerns for
greenhouse gases the role of clouds the
role of water vapor and so many of our
models is is not straightforward it
makes it complex I'm gonna ask you a
question about some work you're doing
here at Yale you are the director and
founder one of the founders of the the
Center for green chemistry and green
engineering here at Yale just give us a
quick overview
of the center and some of the projects
that you're you're most interested in
right now great
so the Center for green chemistry and
green engineering and here at Yale is
focused on just simply measuring
monitoring reviewing or assessing
environmental problems it's saying what
is the and therefore ok we have all of
these challenges and therefore what do
we do about it so it's really an
Innovation Center so doing fundamental
research across the School of Forestry
and environmental studies the chemistry
department the School of Engineering and
but it doesn't end there the the Center
has partnerships and programs with the
School of Law the School of Management
as a School of Public Health the School
of divinity why because it's not simply
about doing basic research it's about
having those discoveries having that
awareness and translating it into
products and processes so that those
will either be new companies new
technologies it'll be spun out so one of
the early companies that was spun out is
something called p2 Sciences that's
right here in New Haven
it makes renewable specialty chemicals
everything from flavors and fragrances
and it's it's really I don't even want
to call it a start-up it's an emerging
company that's that's there and we're
also spinning out things around lignin
technology and catalyst technology some
of our work will also inform next
generation curriculum how does it teach
the next generation of scientists and
engineers some of it might affect policy
but the whole point is that it's not
enough to simply have some scientific
result submitted to a journal and let it
be read by the side it needs to we need
to strive to make sure that it has an
impact
you mentioned the Divinity School I'm
very curious about that what is what are
you doing with the divinities so when
we're talking about sustainable
technologies everybody recognizes that
it's not enough to just have a
technological solution that if you're
going to
install this whether it's in rural
America and the developing world that
you're going to want to make sure that
that technology maybe it's around water
purification or alternative energy is
socially culturally appropriate and so
dealing with those issues we have some
wonderful partners so I think the world
of at the at the Divinity School it's
Mary Evelyn Tucker and John Grimm who
are just tremendously thoughtful in this
area hmm to what extent has green
chemistry become mainstream if it has
and if it hasn't what's it gonna take to
make it mainstream what's it gonna take
for green chemistry to not be an
alternative chemistry but the only
acceptable chemistry yeah no that's a
that's a great way of phrasing it
because I always say that will know when
green chemistry was successful when the
term green chemistry goes away because
when that's simply the way that we
always do chemistry but so I see that
there's good news and then there's
better news okay so the good news is
that there are networks of green
chemistry research and industry and
somewhere around 35 countries around the
world I couldn't even begin to name all
of the companies that are that are
incorporating green chemistry or the
schools that are teaching green
chemistry that's the good news the
better news from my perspective is all
of that activity and all of all of that
research science industry represents
perhaps 1% of the power in the potential
of green chemistry so when a Wall Street
analyst spike research comes out and
puts out a report saying that green
chemistry is expected to go to a hundred
billion dollar industry by 2020 I think
that that's fantastic
but I think that it really touches every
sector question from a viewer this by
email from Neil Burns who asks and to
some same you address this question but
can you cite some chemistry based
companies they're doing interesting
things yeah not just interesting things
but things that you think are the right
things yeah
so that's the that's the issue we we see
innovation out there all the time and I
think innovation is really at the core
heart and soul of of what green
chemistry is all about it's not about
making things less bad it's how do you
design things to be good so what I think
of companies I mentioned P to science
and that's a company that has green
chemistry and it's DNA it's it's not
only making superior products but it's
trying to make products also in a
superior way and so you look at this
whole growing industry the bio-based
economy renewable and specialty
chemicals I think that there's just
tremendous innovation out there right
now back to government for a second you
have a long history with the
Environmental Protection Agency and I
have to say being named by President
Obama to the EPA was the the greatest
professional honor of my career this
really uh it was really quite a quite an
honor to work with the folks down there
because you think about all of the the
stereotypes of government workers I just
don't know of more dedicated
hard-working people it was fantastic I
can imagine yeah so you I mean you have
lived in the belly of the beast of the
science policy universe in the United
States is there a federal agency that
you think is whatever its mission in the
best position to actually have really
meaningful noticeable within our
lifetimes effects on climate change is
it the EPA or is it the Department of
Energy or is it NASA is it the military
right so the the short answer is all of
those agencies and and far more are all
parts of the solution can be parts of
the solution
what's more perhaps
important is that because of their
legally defined missions they're
currently only pieces and they're
fragmented and whenever we've run the
experiment we approach problems in a
fragmented way you're going to wind up
with unintended consequences so do ii
has a certain mission EPA has a certain
mission what we did while I was down in
in Washington is there something called
the National Science and Technology
Council that is ostensibly
run by President Obama and and actively
chaired by his science advisor pulling
together all of the agencies around a
committee called the Committee on
environmental environment Natural
Resources and sustainability so that you
had the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration together with the
National Institutes of Health with EPA
with FDA with USDA all of the different
pieces so that you start getting
alignment so you start getting
integrative systems thinking that is
what's likely necessary in order to get
the drivers moving in the right
direction I'm gonna take another
question this by email from Vahey Morgan
Ian who asks about methane and it sounds
like would like you to elaborate a
little bit why is methane such a potent
greenhouse gas and are we most concerned
with human-made sources of it or natural
sources of it so methane is methane it's
a carbon with four hydrogen's and it
really doesn't care whether it it came
from a natural source or a or a man-made
source and so when we start thinking
about methane as a greenhouse gas and
why it's so potent its potent for the
same reasons that that co2 is and it all
had has to do with the chemical bonds
when you're having the the activation
energy which stretches the bonds of the
carbon and the hydrogen or in the case
of co2 the carbon and the oxygen that's
what makes something a
a greenhouse gas and if if something
does it more more effectively than
another it's a more potent greenhouse
gas so the ranking of all of these gases
is basically an intrinsic property of
those molecules so there are absolutely
natural sources whether it's marshes or
the melting Tundra or other natural
sources but what we're seeing is with
the growth in methane as a fuel source
with with some of the latest
developments and fracking there's a lot
of effort to focus on how much of this
is I'll be coming fugitive emissions and
creating higher concentrations of
nothing in the environment and whether
or not that's leaky or tight that system
is going to be very consequential for
near-term climate change we talked a
fair amount about government's role in
climate change and the way that it might
be done differently and perhaps better
there are individuals now who are
getting very serious about climate
change you may have you may have seen a
story in The New York Times I think it
was yesterday about Tom Styer San
Francisco billionaire who has taken a
serious interest in climate change and
is investing heavily in it times
reported that he may spend as much as a
hundred million dollars trying to
influence elections in order to back
candidates who he thinks will crack down
on activities that are leading to
climate change how in your view can
someone like Tom Steyer be effective hmm
so I guess more than anything else I
come at most of these issues of whether
its climate change or sustainability
generally from the perspective that
innovation is going to be necessary in
order to change the trajectory that
we're on so how do we get that ecosystem
that is necessary in order to facilitate
innovation so
if we try to make things just a little
bit more efficient a little bit a little
bit less bad that's not going to get us
off our climate change trajectory that's
not going to get us off our
unsustainable trajectory that we're on
we need game-changing innovations which
is why I'm so excited about this whole
maker movement this whole idea that
people can invent people can innovate
and when we look right here at Yale at
the the new Center for engineering and
innovation design where students are
making and creating or this is happening
around the u.s. around the world so
people who are interested in changing
what the future looks like I'd suggest
that they be involved in enabling
designing the future to look differently
than it does today because largely
tomorrow is going to look like what we
designed it to look like question by
email from Elizabeth Grossman who asks
is a policy that does not include any
requirement for inherently safer
technology going to adequately prevent
incidents such as their freedom industry
spill in West Virginia
you know the spill in West Virginia is
an absolute tragedy and it's an ongoing
tragedy and it's a it's a shame that it
it makes a few headlines and then goes
away when when so many people can't
drink their water so we've had let's
call it 40 between 40 and 50 years of
environmental policies that try to
control exposure set standards about you
know quite frankly how bad you can be
how much you can pollute and still not
be breaking the law that is an important
step to set a floor that of how
egregious you can be but it's half a
strategy the other strategy has to be
creating a race to the top so the
questioner is asking about can we pursue
inherently safer technology well that's
what green chemistry has been showing
over the past 20 years green chemistry
and green engineering are showing that
you don't have to compromise on
performance you can have
exceptional performance and still make
sure that it's inherently safer
inherently less polluting so I
completely agree that there's a lack of
awareness what's possible but those
possibilities were inherently safer
design sustainable technologies need to
be built into our policies into our laws
I wonder I don't know if I've asked this
and maybe you've answered it in response
to another question but can you cite a
few examples of green chemistry at work
that is green chemistry successfully
done the way you want to see it done the
way it should be done yes certainly when
we talk about a lot of these these
bio-based products that look across the
lifecycle on on how they are not only
less toxic but renewable on the front
end and degradable at the back end those
are a whole class of products when we
look at the area of catalysis than we
mentioned earlier so we could say that
uses lower energy causes less ways uses
less material and at the same time it's
so economically profitable that there
wouldn't be a chemical or petrochemical
company in business without using
catalysis so it's infused in so many
different places of where you can show
that green chemistry is causing
sustainability and profitability at the
same time problem is it's not systemic
and we have countless anecdotes but what
we need to have this be is the default
value for how we make our products and
processes hmm I wonder if you could talk
to us a little bit about what it's like
to have to manage or be part of the
response to a major environmental
disaster and I'm thinking of the BP oil
spill which and correct me if I'm wrong
occurred during your most recent stint
at at EPA yeah it was certainly a
tragedy
the BP oil spill was happened while I
was there Fukushima also happened while
I was there the Fukushima meltdown and
of the nuclear reactors what is what is
interesting is that when we are dealing
with with tragedies crises that we think
it just natural that what we do is we
call together all the different types of
folks around a table you usually have
some kind of nerve center where you'll
react to these things and so you you'll
have the the scientists and the
engineers together with the policy
makers the communication specialists the
lawyers everyone's were on the table all
hands on deck because you know you need
all of those different parts that
happened if the BP oil spill all hands
on deck and happened with Fukushima we
created these nerve centers I think one
of the lessons that that comes out of
these these reactions which you know
thank goodness for the the reactions
because I think that those tragedies as
bad as they were could have been even
worse hmm is that gathering folks
together in a crisis is important but
what if you crisis is happening in slow
motion hmm so we're seeing a lot of
these challenges of sustainability
whether it's our our water quality and
quantity depletion with California
showing a drought that that is just yes
during historic right right and and and
Australia just emerging from one whether
we look at the climate change crisis
these are crises happening in slow
motion by a biodiversity depletion and
we we go through these different issues
the same type of transdisciplinary
integrative thinking will you bring
together all the different perspective
all the different skill sets is is just
as essential to addressing these
problems that happen in slow motion as
they are with the the egregious
explosions and meltdowns hmm clearly
there are individuals or organizations
that are taking climate change very
seriously in this country and elsewhere
do you believe that our society here in
the
States as a society taking climate
change seriously yet the short answer is
not is not seriously enough the short
answer is no so when we look at the
status quo whether it's with climate
change where we're conducting an
uncontrolled experiment on the only
atmosphere that we have whether words
we're talking about chemicals where we
are allowing our products of daily use
for for individuals for children to be
contaminated with things that are going
to potentially cause cancer cause
reproductive and developmental effects
and somehow that that's that's accepted
these are absurdities that historical
absurdities that I I believe we will
look back on and and say how could we
have possibly accepted these things and
taken these things in stride so I
believe the status quo was somewhere
between an absurdity and an obscenity
that we allow these things to happen
contamination of our environment
changing and jeopardizing our children's
health so I am a sworn enemy of the
status quo which is why I think
innovation and sustainable innovation is
the the only path forward so if we look
at climate change it it's always viewed
as something off in the future even
though we're seeing it happening all
around us now when we look at many of
these toxic effects we we think of them
as happening to some to someone else yet
we all know someone who has suffered
from them if we ourselves haven't so
yeah we need to change the status quo
and we need to do it rapidly I've been
asking most of the questions the viewers
of ask them questions we're gonna wrap
it up in just a minute but I want to
give you a chance to sort of offer a
parting thought if there's one thing
that you would like to leave the viewers
with today about what one thought about
green chemistry about the environment
about climate change about science
policy
yeah what is it that that green
chemistry green engineering sustainable
design it's all about innovation it's
all about the promise that creativity
brings to us and so you know we we think
that all that we have and I mentioned
earlier all that we have in this world
is energy and matter that's that's all
we have well the truth of the matter is
that's not all we have we have
creativity we have spirit we have
innovation we have commitment we have
dedication and the power and potential
of green chemistry green engineering
sustainable design is to get us off our
current trajectory and do it in a way
that's going to result in just a far
better world Paul Anastos thanks for
joining us and at Yale live and thanks
to all of you for watching at Yale live
join us again next time
you